this is such a stereotype come on
welcome to scotland
lots of people follow this youtube
channel because of the vlogs i made
during my phd in atmospheric physics at
the university of exeter unfortunately
however i had to graduate at some point
and that necessarily meant the end of my
videos showing what doing a phd was like
however there are lots of people out
there doing interesting phd projects and
so in this video series i'm spending a
few days with a new researcher each
episode showing you what that life is
like learning a bit about them and
learning about the topic of their thesis
i'm here at the university of andrews to
talk to emma a phd student who's
researching how exoplanets have been
depicted in science fiction
there is however
one small problem oh boy that would be
difficult
so um yeah you got covert didn't you
yeah on the morning that you arrived i
emailed you probably just after you had
gotten off your sleeper train yep that's
exactly what happened and uh just this
morning i am finally free i've been in
isolation for ten days because i just
kept testing positive but uh feeling
significantly better now my voice was
gone for a while it's back now very very
unfortunate timing i'm also up here
giving some talks to the physics
department so it's not like i came all
this way for nothing well it's also not
like i came here for nothing because
this is a very pretty town here's how
this video is going to work emma and i
are going to be chatting over zoom about
her phd and you're going to be seeing
some footage from me that i took in
andrews whilst i was up there and you're
also going to see some footage from emma
instant andrews because she very kindly
volunteered to vlog some of her time and
we'll all find out together if this
video will actually work for now over to
emma to talk about what her thesis is
roughly about so i study exoplanets
which are planets outside our solar
system but i don't study the real ones i
study the fictional ones as they appear
in science fiction because real
exoplanets were discovered very recently
just in the 1990s
but people have been writing about
planets outside our solar system for
much much longer so i'm making a
database of fictional exoplanets and
seeing how the way writers have
constructed them has changed before and
after the discovery of real exoplanets
i'm creating a database and i want it to
be fairly representative obviously of
before and after the discovery of real
exoplanets but also of
hard science fiction which is more
technically accurate and soft science
fiction which is more
space opera could be magic except
they're not calling it that so i started
with a bunch of things that i was
familiar with and then i ended up making
a google form so i'm crowdsourcing it is
uh the pinned tweet on my twitter it's
on my website all sorts of things you
can submit any fictional exoplanet that
you've heard of when people study
literature usually they're doing close
reading you'll be looking at one book
often you can write an entire paper on
just like one chapter of one book and
that's close reading but that's not
going to tell me anything about what
exoplanets are like across all of
science fiction so i am purposely
abstracting my data i'm purposely losing
a lot of information about every planet
in order to see a bigger picture and
wider trends so for each planet that
goes in i have these nine
categories nine variables that i answer
about it and they're almost all yes no
questions except for
the one that is the media type
so the media type i have
movies books tv shows podcasts and video
games so then the way i analyze all of
this stuff is i use this software called
banjo which is the bayesian interference
software to create bayesian networks so
bayesian networks are like all these
little variables are bubbles and then
there's arrows connecting them that
represent conditional dependencies
between the variables so a bayesian
network is sort of saying if we have
more background information about a
thing we can make better predictions so
for example if a planet is
not a gas giant if it has humans and
those humans are non-native humans
whether it's more likely that that
planet was written about before or after
the discovery of real exoplanets yes so
the yeah the variables will positively
or negatively influence each other's if
one thing is true it might be more it
might make it more or less likely that
another thing is true so i'm most
interested in this before after variable
and the things so far that i've found
that are connected with that is i've
found that
before after
negatively influences
intelligent so
after the discovery of real exoplanets
there's uh i'm finding fewer portrayals
of intelligent native life on exoplanets
[Music]
i've got scottish relatives who live on
the isle of skye and i've visited
scotland absolutely tons of times and so
i mean i just love it here i think this
is probably the best part of the uk to
be completely honest with you like i
like living in the west country but
it doesn't get much better than this
this is so beautiful
also if i tilt the camera over this way
if you're into golf
that's the old course over that way
apparently that's a big thing for i
don't know i don't know golf one of the
nice things about pandemic is that
you're not expected to come into the
office all the time um so i think my
preference is probably about three days
in the office and two days not in a week
i wake up go to wherever i end up
working for the day i'll usually
check my email it turns out grad school
is like 50
email monitoring seeing if i have any
meetings with anybody that day it's
monday
and later this afternoon i will be
presenting my research at the scottish
exoplanet and brown dwarf spring meeting
2022
i've attended before but this is my
first time presenting my research so i'm
going to be spending this morning just
adding finishing touches to my
powerpoint and going through my talk
once or twice to make sure i've got it
down and then i'll be heading over to
the office later in the day
presentation practiced i am heading into
the office and just going to grab some
lunch on the way but i just want to show
off that this gorgeous alleyway is part
of my commute and i'm still in awe about
that
lunch and coffee acquired
so here i am presenting a database of
fictional exoplanets and a bayesian
network analysis of that database
essentially i'm defining it as stories
that extrapolate from some element of
science they feature an estrangement or
a major difference from our real world
and they're really
fiction of what ifs so i'm now back home
after an afternoon of first presenting
and then listening to a whole bunch of
presentations about exoplanets and brown
dwarfs and i think my presentation went
pretty well i felt pretty good about it
i went first which is always nice
because then i can sit back and relax
and enjoy the rest of the presentations
afterwards but i got some good questions
and it was just so nice to do this in
person
this is the first time that this
particular meeting has run in person in
two years and it was lovely to get to
meet a lot of people who had been names
in my email folder before this but when
i'm actually doing my research
i'll either be doing background reading
or i'll be hunting for new planets
occasionally just breaking down and
emailing an author and usually they get
back to me actually are there any
interesting authors that you've had
reply to charlie strauss and he
responded in two minutes and i was a
little bit frightened
i would be
i'm also the telescope trainer for
undergrads who want to get trained on
how to use the telescopes that are
observatory we have the big one the
james gregory telescope is used for
research but the other ones are pretty
much just used to train undergrads who
want to learn some observational
astronomy and then they can just come
and do some recreational stargazing in a
way saint andrews feels like a mix of
both oxford and exeter like the two
universities i know very well in that
there's a lot of very lovely old
buildings here it's not a collegiate
university but the uni owns
you know houses and stuff scattered all
throughout i just passed the metaphysics
department like the divinity school's
just over there as the physics
department's way over there like there
is no one central campus but it somehow
feels like exeter
i don't know if it's just because of the
posh reputation i'm very lucky it's
actually very sunny today um yeah what a
lovely place to go to uni
look snow cloud and there's i don't know
how visible it is on camera but there's
just a light snow falling
what the heck scotland i really should
get better at filming these but um
i i did just do a talk i didn't i i got
look here's a clip of the audience i did
do a talk i think it went well don't you
yeah not bad
i've never liked just doing one subject
i described myself somewhat jokingly as
too interdisciplinary to function when i
was like 12 i really wanted to be a
writer that was what i was going to do i
didn't like science at all then at some
point in middle school science i decided
i liked science and i went to a
stem-focused high school and i found
astronomy and i really liked astronomy
and then in undergrad i went to
swarthmore college in the u.s double
majored in astronomy and history i
started thinking about grad school but i
was like well phds are meant to be deep
dives into one subject so how am i
possibly going to ever do a phd even if
i wanted to and i applied to a whole
bunch of just astronomy programs i
didn't get into any of them because i
didn't have enough research but one of
my professors from undergrad forwarded
me this strange scholarship from the
university of saint andrews he was like
you're one of the only people who i
think might be qualified for this
because they were looking for either
somebody who studied literature but knew
some computer science or a physicist who
really liked to write or something like
that because they wanted to do this
project of applying data science to
science fiction and it sounded really
flexible and like i could sort of make
the project my own uh so i applied and
then i got in and i found out that i had
got it a couple weeks before the
pandemic started
um
so i got the acceptance email on like
february 18th 2020 or something like
that and then moved here without knowing
anybody in this country
and how does scotland compare to the
united states um
well it's very different it's much
colder it's a very obvious surface level
thing to say but the people are really
friendly i can vote in the scottish
council elections i think that's really
neat i still haven't tried haggis that's
the first thing anybody asks me when i
go to the u.s what about iron brew yes i
have tried iron brew i actually tried
that in my first isolation i noticed all
the restaurants had had this thing
called earn brew and i'm like what's urn
brew
so i googled it quickly found out how
it's actually pronounced um and then
ordered some and uh i actually filmed my
first time tasting it i could send that
to you if you want because i didn't make
a face
what's it like to study in saint andrews
oh it's really neat it's um
perfect for me i'm not a city person so
i don't like big cities so it's it's a
fairly small town but it's got probably
like 10 different coffee shops and cafes
which is all i need it's right by the
sea i think there's just this kind of
when humans are near crashing waves they
just calm down a bit so i can just go
walk by the sea whenever i need to you
see that behind me
that's the beach where they filmed the
famous running scene and chariots of
fire
the one time i don't bring my running
kit on one of these trips
and it's probably the most famous
running location in the entire country
there's old stone ruins everywhere the
only thing that's really missing is a
good forest i can sort of pretend by
walking uh by the burn by laid brays
i downloaded some podcasts called the
scottish history podcast and just kind
of walked around listening to it going
on long pandemic walks because i just
realized i was standing a place where i
didn't really know the history and that
kind of unnerved me so like i need to
learn so i did it was great well moving
here and trying to integrate with a
research group when
everything is just video calls has been
challenging but
but i've done it i mean there's nothing
else to do but just do it when you're in
a weird situation because of covid like
i don't have a peer who's doing the same
thing that i am i just
mostly i'm administratively with the
physics and astronomy school i have an
office i've well a desk in an office in
the physics and astronomy building and
so i mostly interact with them she's a
very tidy desk didn't she
one thing that i am able to do austin
andrews though is
join well i say joint derail a twitch
stream yeah this is thomas you are the
president of the school of physics yes
um
for now yes uh until the coup
uh and uh you invited me up here to give
some talks so we just actually had one
on science communication and we've got
one this evening but between them we now
have a live stream uh which we'll put
the url up on the screen and in the
description but you stream pretty
regularly and you're doing it what we're
doing today a lot of the time which is
past papers but specifically a scottish
past paper yeah because they're a bit
different are they harder
what's that before the x plus y squared
oh great i can't read it either that's
not a partial derivative everything else
i'm doing is like partial derivatives at
the minute because lagrangian dynamics
wait do you start your sixes at the top
yeah like a normal person what
one two normal three
four weird
six
that's sort of six that's a gamma that's
a gamma completely different
they're the same thing i've said before
that humanity students have to work so
much harder to get funding for a phd and
when they have it they often have to be
very creative with that funding and emma
is no exception because not only has she
produced an anthology of short stories
and poetry created by exoplanetary
scientists working with artists she's
been working on her own original sci-fi
concept which is going to be premiering
soon so rogue maker is
my audio drama podcast it began
over a year ago as a live-action
role-playing game that i played with my
friends um i wrote it as a larp that we
could do audio only over discord again
because i was thinking about how much of
my life exists in the audio but the
premise is that we're in the far future
we're on a commercial space flight um
something goes wrong and the ship
explodes and everybody ends up in these
scattered escape pods
that have all sorts of communication
difficulties reaching each other and
somebody did blow up the ship and they
have to figure out who did that why that
person did that and where they're going
now but we're in the far future as i
said there are humans there are also
aliens and they come from a tidally
locked planet which was really
fascinating from a world building
perspective because i had to think about
like their entire history as a species
how they evolved so
what you're doing is creating a whole
new exoplanet which is informed by all
this modern science
which can then form part of the database
that you're constructing yeah my plan
that planet actually is in my database
now i guess i sort of realized that i've
always been studying things because i'm
passionate about them in a fictional
sense like i i
double majored in history and astronomy
my two favorite genres are historical
fiction and science fiction um
so i just had this realization that i've
been doing this for much longer i'm just
doing it officially now where i'm sort
of studying something that is my passion
and it's a strange
balancing act to like know when i'm
working versus when i'm doing something
for my hobby but it is basically my
second full-time job right now i go home
and i edit audio and
um our trailer is out now and our show
is premiering on star wars day on may
the 4th it's on spotify it's on apple
podcasts google podcasts all the normal
ones
we're on twitter at roguemakerpod
and if you have a favorite podcast app
that we are not on you can just pm us
and i will i will see what i can do to
get us on there
awesome
so what's the plan now once you finish
the phd what are you gonna do next like
i said i really i would really like to
work in um science communication public
outreach for a science organization or a
museum or or whoever
i really like talking to people about
exoplanets and i get really excited when
i do it so i think that would be a very
fun job in a perfect world i would just
be a science fiction author and i would
make enough money off of that but i
don't think that's likely to happen i
know that that's something that i will
continue to do no matter what else i do
obviously because i'm doing it currently
with rogue maker i also
could end up being a data scientist if
i'm not able to find a job in science
communication um so i think i've got
options
even though it's a pretty out there phd
that that's that's what's next where
that would end up being i have no idea
i don't know if i want to stay in the uk
or go to the us or earth probably
earth probably
yeah no the more i learn about
exoplanets the more i never want to go
to one
i hope this video has made you excited
about the study of exoplanets because
with the launch of the james webb space
telescope scientists are about to
discover thousands more some of which
will be unlike anything we've ever seen
before to understand the headlines that
are about to come out and learn more
about how we discover exoplanets check
out the astronomy course on brilliant
this video sponsor that course
introduces you to world beyond earth the
life cycles of stars and cosmology and
like the rest of brilliant does so
through interactive exercises bite-sized
chunks of information and expertly
written questions that emphasize
learning by doing and that mistakes are
just learning opportunities however
brilliant is about much more than just
astronomy it's a tool available on
desktop and on mobile to support
lifelong learning in science computer
science and maths that means it's ideal
to supplement classroom learning for
students but also for adults who aren't
done with learning about the world and
want to do so in a meaningful way in
their own time i've used brilliant for a
while now across a wide range of
subjects and i've never been less than
impressed it has beautiful art the
exercises and courses are well thought
through and it works i understand stuff
now that i didn't before and that's the
best recommendation i can give head on
over to brilliant.org simon clark to
sign up and the first 200 people to do
so will get an amazing 20 discount of a
premium annual subscription for
themselves or a student in their lives
with thanks to brilliant for their
ongoing support at this channel thank
you so much for watching the video if
you haven't already check out the
description because there's links to
emma's socials and also roguemaker which
will be premiering very soon if you
enjoyed this video here's a playlist
with all the other episodes in the
series and there's another
recommendation for viewing just down
there please do subscribe to the channel
if you haven't already and if you
enjoyed the video please do pop it a
like and tell people about it who you
think may find it interesting that just
leads me to say thank you again for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one